James reportedly you were offered 50
million dollars to stay in late night
television I know there are things you
want to do and you are talented and
you've you know you've acted on TV I
mean you you're you're even your career
Direction wasn't a late night TV show
but that's a tremendous amount of money
the decision to leave the show is based
on so many there's so many factors that
it is pretty impossible to to drill it
down to one and really for my wife and I
we always knew and we said this like
four
four years five years ago we were like
when Max is my eldest son when
he finishes sixth grade
that is a real
moment for us where we knew and we
always felt and I've always said that to
move
14 15 16 year olds around
you know even if we went Coast to Coast
or internationally felt unfair at the
point when he is would be forging his
life of his you know what I mean making
friends deeper friendships deeper
connections it felt very very unfair to
us so we knew that this was a decision
that we would have to make where and
then our you know our daughter after
that is eight and our youngest daughter
is five so
if we were going to stay we'd be staying
in Los Angeles for 20 years we'd be here
for 20 years and that would be it and so
that is the absolute Crux of the
decision is where do we want to raise
these these people that we've brought
into the world these and in truth like
our my family
and I think this might resonate with you
but like my family has walked to the
beat of my drum for like
12 13 years now right where you know I'm
going to do a play in New York I'm going
to shoot this over here I'm going to be
gone for a bit and do you know and
really
for us it was like where do we want to
raise our children there are people at
home who are getting older and we really
felt that during covid and I think
everybody felt that's not even even if
your family were two states away you
felt it you felt cut off from everybody
and there was a couple of health things
that that came along that made us just
feel like there are too many signs here
telling us to go home
and so look
if I allow myself to think about the
financial aspects of walking away from
this it does it makes
my chest tight because who would I get
it I get it why would you do such a
thing but then the truth is
time with my parents
to be able to
to be able to call my dad on a Thursday
and go what you doing today and he's
saying nothing and I said you want to go
for lunch
that is a feeling that I'll just never
ever ever get back and one day the the
time's gonna come it's not up to us when
that is or when we choose it but the
phone's going to ring and that option's
not going to be there anymore
and to have missed out on those moments
in exchange for money
doesn't feel
like a good
decision
and I I'm so aware of time I feel like
time is
time is Playing Tricks on Me in a way
that I am deeply uncomfortable with I
feel like my son
learned to ride a bike yesterday you
know right and I just
feel like it is it is a feeling of going
we've got to
if we don't jump now
and if not now when
and that's really what it came down to
promise me you don't start an only fans
or uh
I cannot
I cannot promise you anything at this
moment because you know
I think we can all agree that would be
far more profitable for me than any
contract CBS could offer